ل المتابعه معنا الان من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام خسائر كبيره في
الارواح من قتلى وجرحى في صفوف جيش
الاحتلال هذا ما اعلنته الجهات الرسميه
ولكن ماذا في اطار ردود الفعل على ما تم
اعلانه حتى اللحظه
الياس ازدهار واضح بان الحصيله ثقيله
ومؤلمه وكارثه وصعبه بحسب توصيفات الجيش
الاسرائيلي القيادات السياسيه والعسكريه
في اسرائيل بعد الاعلان عن مقتل 21 جنديا
وضابطا في هذه العمليه في المخيمات الوسطى
لقطاع غزه وواضح بان ردود الفعل تاتي
منسجمه مع هذه الفاتوره الثقيله التي
يدفعها الجيش الاسرائيلي في سياق حربه على
قطاع غزه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف
جالانت اشار في معرض تعقيبه على هذا
الاعلان ان هذه هذا العدد الكبير من
القتلى والجرحى في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
هو بمثابه وصيه كما سماها من اجل
الاستمرار في هذه العمليه العسكريه حتى
تحقيق اهدافها وايضا وزير الامن القومي
ايتمار بنفير تحدث في نفس السياق عن ان
دماء الجنود والضباط يجب انلا يذهب سدى في
اطار هذه العمليه العسكريه وان الحرب يجب
ان تتصاعد وتستمر و هذا ما يعبر عنه حقيقه
عدد كبير من السياسيين والعسكريين في
اسرائيل في اعقاب هذا الحدث المؤلم بحسب
توصيفهم والكارثي والذي ادى الى مقتل 21
من الضباط والجنود الاسرائيليين طبيعه
الحال هنالك من كان حذر من ان العمليات
الاسرائيليه في داخل قطاع غزه التي باتت
تراوح مكانها تحديدا في المناطق الشماليه
والوسطى لقطاع غزه من شانها ان تكبد الجيش
الاسرائيلي خسائر فادحه في الارواح وتبقي
القوات الاسرائيليه عرضه لهجمات قد تؤدي
الى مزيد من القتلى والجرحى في صفوفهم
لذلك نحن استمعنا في الايام الماضيه الى
اراء خبراء عسكريين سابقين في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وعلى راسهم اللواء المتقاعد
يحاك بريك الذي كان حذر الجيش الاسرائيلي
من ان عملياته العسكريه التي تراوح مكانها
في قطاع غزه من شانها ان تكبد الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتلى وجرحى وخسائر فادحه وهذا
تحقق ونحن نشير الى يتسحاك بريك دائما في
مداخلات وحديثنا عن الوضع العسكري لان
بريك كان من بين الضباط او هو الضابط
الوحيد الذي كان توقع هجمات السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي بحذافيرها واشار الى تفاصيل
وسيناريو كل ما حصل في السابع من اكتوبر
وهو كان من بين الجنرالات الذين قاموا
بفحص قدرات الجيش الاسرائيلي ل تحديدا
القوات العسكريه من قوات المشاه والمدرعات
وفيما اذا كانت جاهزه وعلى قدر من
الجاهزيه لاي حرب مقبله واشار في تقاريره
الى ان الجيش غير جاهز لذلك الجيش بحد
ذاته كيف يبرر الوقوع في كل هذه الاخطاء
ان صح التعبير كنت ايضا انت على الهواء
اثناء
مداخله
وتابعت بشكل مباشر ذلك التفجير في المغار
بشكل كبير ولافت كيف يتم التبرير على
المستوى العسكري كل
ذلك بالفعل ازدهار نحن كنا بالامس على بعد
كيلومتر ونصف تقريبا من السياج الامني في
الموقع الذي وقع فيه هذا التفجير وحقيقه
بان الارض قد اهتزت تحت اقدامنا في اعقاب
هذا الانفجار وهذا يعطيك فكره ازدهار عن
حجم هذا الانفجار الهائل الذي حدث في
المبنيين المستهدفين وكميه المتفجرات التي
كانت موجوده في داخل المبنيين عقب ذلك
ايضا ازدهار سلسله من الغارات الجويه
العنيفه التي شنها سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
على تلك المنطقه التي شهدت هذا الانفجار
وكان ذلك مصحوبا ايضا بكثافه من النيران
من جانب المدفعيه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
في منطقه غلاف غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ازدهار يقول بانه كان يعمل في هذين
المبنيين في اطار عمليه تفجير ل المنشات
القريبه من السياج الاميني نح نتحدث عن
موقع الانفجار وهو على بعد نحو 600 متر
بحسب التقديرات العسكريه لاسرائيل عن
السياج الامني وكنا قد اشرنا ازدهار في
الاسابيع الماضيه وكشفنا حقيقه عن ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم بعمليه تدمير
ممنهجه لكل المنشات الصناعيه والتجاريه
وحتى المباني السكنيه القريبه من السياج
الامني والقريبه تحديدا من البلدات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه غلاف غزه على اعتبار
ان ثمه رؤيه عسكريه لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي
يريد ان يحققها في تلك المنطقه وهي خلق
عمق استراتيجي او عمق امني ان صح التعبير
ما بين السياج الامني وما بين البلدات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه الغلاف على نحو تكون
هذه المنطقه خاضعه للسيطره امنيه ومراقبه
امنيه اسرائيليه بعد انتهاء الحرب وتوفر
عمقا امنيا ايضا للبلدات الاسرائيليه
القريبه جدا من السياج الامني في منطقه
غلاب غزه لذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يعمل
على تفجير هذه المنشات او هذه المباني
ويبدو انه وضع كميه كبيره من المتفجرات
هناك قوات من الهندسه وقوات من المدرعات
كانت تؤمن عمليه التفخيخ وا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه استهدفت هذه القوات على الاقل
بحسب التقديرات الاوليه بقذيفتين من نوع
ار بي جي واحده اصابت احدى الدبابات التي
كانت ضمن قوه الحراسه والحمايه التي كانت
تحيط في هذه المباني المستهدفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان جنديين قتلا في داخل
الدبابه جراء هذا الاستهداف فيما ان
القذيفه الثانيه اصابت احد المبنيين وادت
الى انهياره ما بشكل تام بفعل ما كان
بداخلهما من عبوات
ناسفه كانت معده للتفجير عن بعد لكن يبدو
ان القذيفه التي وجهت الى احد المبنيين
ادت الى تفعيل هذه المنظومه منظومه
المتفجرات والتفخيخ التي كانت اليش
الاسرائيلي قد وضعها وهذا ما يفسر حقيقه
انهيار المبنيين بشكل تام وهذا تطلب من
الجيش الاسرائيلي ساعات كثيره حتى صباح
هذا اليوم لرفع الانقاد وانتشال جثث
الجنود والضباط الاسرائيليين من تحت انقاد
هذين المبنيين هذه هي
العمليه الاصعب
والحصيله الاقصى بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي
بعد هجوم السابع من اكتوبر ال الماضي
الهجوم الكبير الذي اودى بحياه مئات من
الجنود والضباط الاسرائيليين لكنه ايضا
ياتي في اطار سلسله من العمليات الاخرى
التي كانت اوقعت اعدادا كبيره من الجنود
والضباط الاسرائيليين بين قتيل وجريح